I'm sure you all have the ability to unconsciously avoid
death.I'd like you to take a test to prove
it.What kind of test is it?
If
you
draw a sex card from these cards, you will succeed, and if you draw a sex card,
you will
fail.  Is
there
anyone who
wants to draw a
card?
Let me do it, please pull it out The
squirrel is very careful because it's a
test
I know it's
pretty stupid
Master of the Labyrinth This
is
my secret power that no one knows The
debt test is about to begin
I wanted you to know that the experiment is not a game
What is an experiment What do you think human life is
What is the difference between a cancerous student and death?